en realidad hay varios eclipses por año
hay aproximadamente cinco eclipses
totales de sol el problema es que tiene
una región muy limitado donde se puede
ver
imagínate que este eclipse en particular
el camino que hizo tenían menos de 100
kilómetros de ancho entonces muy poca
gente que puede estar por eso es tan
raro que se dé en un mismo lugar varias
veces señor martínez en palabras
sencillas cómo se define el punto de la
tierra en el que será visible este tipo
de fenómeno
se hace por cálculo uno puede calcular
dado el movimiento del sol la tierra y
la luna se calcula con una precisión
enorme dónde va a estar la sombra
recorriendo sobre la superficie de la
tierra y se puede llegar a saber el
lugar exacto con un error de segundos ya
esto puedo predecir cómo hace cuándo
empezar y terminar el eclipse con
segundos vimos en las imágenes que
muchas de las personas que se reunieron
a ver este eclipse lo hicieron sin
protección ocular esto es peligroso si
lamentablemente mucha gente por la
ansiedad de tratar de verlo no usa lo
apropiado entonces a veces te dicen que
una radiografía sirve u otros pronto
pero en realidad hay que usar una
determinada cantidad cosas como un
filtro especial para soldar de densidad
14 o filtros de lo que son anteojitos de
cartón que son específicamente para ver
el eclipse porque produce ceguera
simplemente simple y lisa y llanamente
produce ceguera
discúlpeme también le pregunto cuándo
podrán países americanos volver a
disfrutar de fenómenos similares
en américa va a haber varios todavía lo
que pasa es que uno como este que cruce
por argentina va a ceder al año 2048 por
eso es un fenómeno son raros en el mismo
lugar